welcome to this video against dadaism
wins dadaism wins never played that guy
it's got a name nope quite a new account
so he's six let's go back to to the sea
three SS ayan so he's just going for
this thing I could have played d5
actually ah maybe I should have done
that yeah there are some tricks and this
in this lines in this lines with the
knight c6 and things I should 55 that's
it's better ok that's not the ideal move
but I have to make a decision I think
after Queen eat we will take on deform
plain knight c6 would not be form this
this kind of stuff oh I don't know
but this cannot be really bad for for
Wyatt that should be an ok position at
least that sets early Quincy 7
okay I mean early because sometimes yeah
and now it takes this is kind of curious
why do you misplace the Queen on c7 and
then open up the position that's really
interesting okay okay let's see I want
to get denied to be five quickly opening
up the pollution okay so d 5 is going to
play night before 9 p-5 Bishop f4 is
possible or move like Bishop g5 yeah
just preventing or making the
development a bit more difficult here
blacklegs problem is the lack of
development and the queen is vulnerable
on c7 I'm going to play Luke c1 and t5
this is the idea Bishop e7 I will take
and plane I'd be 52 d 6 yeah that move
okay where to go probably he I am
covering f3 and c2
yeah look see one is the the next move
if he allows it one I'd be five yeah
maybe not be five and then look see one
ok so night b5 he wants to go to be
eight it seems
Jim probably
it's really hard to believe that this
should work might be five okay let's
let's play the move and then see what
what's happening and some eggs and rooks
even one annoys them I mean there's
always 97 is almost assistances chess
sitting in a min mating ideas here 96
and maybe he can just about who would it
queen three moves as 97 and I'm
Winningham queencess em luc c7 and then
whoopsie eight made so he has to play
knight c6 so what about this knight c6
hmm do I have a winner after knight c6
it looks like there should be one okay
yeah d5 and 96 then it's very strong
right I am okay yeah yeah winning with
97 if i'm not mistaken check Queen takes
rook takes Bishop e2 look see a
checkmate maybe he can take on c7 rook
takes and then from black exactly i
cannot it was really just winning yeah
he totally neglected development him
let's let's have a look here right here
might be five has to do that txt ya
knight c6 is the only move that add that
I could see but I thought that maybe d5
would be interesting but it's not not
completely not working him he can take
with the pawn and then I was thinking 96
but this is just bleep easy this is
check check but he can also just take
the queen is so this doesn't make any
sense this however does make some sense
intending maybe also night f5 to d6 it's
a very strong attack without any any
doubt yeah the computer likes white
Joneses plus one point one looks very
nice form for white however I don't
necessarily need to do that it looks
very logical because it gets the night
into the game so quickly and I probably
wouldn't played that it just looks looks
like the way to go to go getting all
pieces right into the
that's a very tricky position for black
chick sticks is the computers top choice
and then aged 69 96 is maybe not so
convincing check yeah that's better for
white but maybe not the best possible
way Queen here's the computer move
intending what likee six maybe now it's
not much fun to defend this I think one
problem was that some moves I don't
really know if this is any good and then
taking I mean this this loses really
really lots of time and I'm developing
very very quickly here maybe a three was
even better edits the computer move a 3
really preventing that and then going
for d5 yeah maybe this is this is
probably strong I am and here yeah this
is this is ultimately the real problem
h6 seems to be better now now that's
better in comparison right if I go back
here he has g5 it looks it looks weird
but it's possibly just good because the
bishop now is not protecting see one now
and I cannot easily remove the night
some way I can take on c1 with the Queen
yeah this is what it should have done
yeah probably the computer here is right
after 96 I should go here and really
take this move out of the equation and
then d 5 is a really really strong idea
when the Black Knight has nowhere to go
really you don't want to take and you
cannot go to a 5 really yeah that's
better okay i hope you liked it thanks
for watching